today on the matt walsh show canada has
just effectively criminalized biblical
sexual morality and biological science
they'll they call it a ban on conversion
therapy we have laws like this the
united states as well uh but they're not
what they first appear so we'll look at
that today also we'll discuss um the
jihadist who took hostages at a
synagogue in texas but the fbi biden and
the media are pretending to be puzzled
about his motives i mean why could he
have possibly done this and if glenn
younkin's first day as governor is any
indication then he's going to have a
brilliant tenure we'll talk about what
he did on his first day and
what is an after-school satan club
exactly we'll find out today
unfortunately and much more on the
matter
[Music]
well very excited to announce today uh a
new sponsor and new partner um on the
show and uh for for the year ahead and
that is naturally it's clean now when
you bring a product into your home you
want to be sure that your hard-earned
money is going to a brand that believes
in the same principles as you
and i could tell you that i've met with
these guys the founders of um naturally
it's clean and they definitely are on
our team in a major way and they're
they're they are members of the sweet
baby game okay so these these guys
they're they're one of us naturally it's
clean is a home cleaning company
dedicated to providing the most
effective cleaning products for your
home while reducing the use of harmful
chemicals what's their secret well
powerful plant-based enzymes which is
nature solution to cleaning and when i
say powerful i'm talking about
hospital-grade enzyme cleaning powder
they have um cleaning power i should say
not powder they have solutions for
almost every need in the house from the
kitchen to the bathroom to the laundry
room naturally it's clean as a
specialized formula to clean the area
effectively that's why i'm encouraging
my listeners to start with four of their
top products conveniently packaged
together in their daily wire essentials
kit this is something they put together
just for daily wire listeners and for a
limited time my listeners can receive 15
off their order just enter promo code
matt at checkout when you visit
naturallyitsclean.com
matt try these incredible products in
your home today i've tried them in mine
and you know when i've got um four kids
in the house we have plenty of
opportunities to use cleaning products
i'll just put it that way and uh nothing
better than naturally it's clean
shipping is free and everything is made
right here in the usa so again try our
naturally it's clean daily wire four
pack today by going to
naturallyitsclean.com
and use promo code matt to receive 15
off your purchase don't delay make the
smarter safer choice for your home
cleaning needs today with naturally it's
clean
so last week canada finally enacted its
nationwide ban on so-called conversion
therapy our neighbors to the north uh
now join several other countries like
germany and brazil
and uh up to i think 20 u.s states now
in banning the alleged practice though
the canadian law ups the ante
considerably under the statute as the as
the new york times reports it is a crime
to quote
provide or promote services intended to
change or repress a person's sexual
orientation or gender expression
and violators who are found guilty of
engaging in this illicit activity will
be subject to five years in prison and
those who merely don't even engage in it
but promote it are looking at two years
behind bars
now this immediately raises a question
that most corporate media articles on
the subject have uh not really bothered
to answer but pretty obvious question
which is
what is it what are we talking about
what's what specifically is
conversion therapy we've all heard the
the phrase before
um but what is it now left-wing
propaganda about the practice which
often uses words like barbaric and
violent and brutal to describe it brings
to mind images of homosexuals you know
committed against their will to insane
asylums in straitjackets maybe strapped
to gurneys and given electric shocks
until they change their mind about their
sexual orientation
but that sort of thing isn't happening
in the modern western world so what then
do these conversion therapy prohibitions
actually prohibit
well for that answer we should probably
turn to the legislation itself i think
it's probably the best place to go uh
bill c4
which begins by telling us that quote
conversion therapy causes harm to
society because among other things it is
based on and propagates myths and
stereotypes about sexual orientation
gender identity and gender expression
including the myth that heterosexuality
cisgender gender identity and gender
expression that conform to the sex
assigned to person at birth are to be
preferred over other sexual orientations
gender identities and gender expressions
now
in one fell swoop here
um
sexual morality as it is understood by
billions of people across the world and
throughout history and has been taught
by every major world religion for
thousands of years
has been legally consigned to the status
of myth
and the belief that it's better for a
person to accept their biological
identity than to than to try and reject
it in favor of an identity that they can
never truly obtain
a belief shared by nearly every human
being who has ever walked the earth
joins biblical sex morality under the
fairy tale umbrella because that's a
myth too
but we still don't know what exactly
conversion therapy is right
now fortunately there's a section of the
bill which purports to offer a
definition in fact it says definition of
conversion therapy
okay that's good now here's what it says
conversion therapy means a practice
treatment or service designed to
a
change a person's sexual orientation to
heterosexual
change a person's gender identity to
cisgender
c change a person's gender expression so
that it conforms to the sex assigned to
the person at birth
d repress or reduce non-heterosexual
attraction or sexual behavior
e repress a person's non-cisgender
gender identity or f
repress or reduce a person's gender
expression that does not conform to the
sex assigned to the person at birth
and then it continues and says for
greater certainty this definition does
not include a practice treatment or
service that relates to the exploration
or development of an of an integrated
personal identity such as a practice
treatment or service that relates to a
person's gender transition and that is
not based on an assumption that a
particular sexual orientation gender
identity or gender expression is to be
preferred over another
now the wording here is still quite
vague
by by design i mean this is intentional
but it's clear that conversion therapy
certainly need not involve straight
jackets or electric shocks
so we're way beyond that
any
practice treatment or service
you think about the word practice
what is a practice it's just a thing
that you do so just anything at all
which seeks to in any way
quote change or repress a person's quote
non-cisgender identity or
non-heterosexual attraction is
conversion therapy
and could land you in prison for half a
decade
now under this definition
there is no conversion taking place when
a young boy is say chemically castrated
in order to make him look more like a
girl
or when a young girl is given a double
mastectomy in order to make her look
more like a boy
you know that's not conversion rather it
is conversion
if they are convinced not to be
butchered in this way
if you convince them not to do this
if you convince a girl not to go have
her breasts chopped off
then you are guilty of conversion
therapy
for convincing her to keep the body she
was born with
um by encouraging a boy
to accept the fact that he is a boy or
encouraging a girl except the fact that
she's a girl you are engaging in
conversion therapy under this law
it is conversion therapy to explain to a
male that he is male
and to help him embrace his natural
identity
if you simply said to a boy well you're
a biological male that means you're a
boy that's conversion therapy
according to this
now does that mean
that any counselor therapist teacher
pastor or even parent who refuses to
encourage a child's gender delusion is
guilty of violating this law and could
end up behind bars for five years
yeah that's explicitly what it means
does it mean that any priest or minister
who stands at the pulpit on sunday and
preaches about sexual morality
not a lot of them doing that in canada
or in the united states but if they do
it
or even read a passage from the bible
like you know romans
1
26-27
one of the
many biblical passages which condemns
the homosexual act um does that mean
that that anyone who does that is now a
conversion therapist and liable to a
lengthy prison sentence yeah again
that's very clearly what it means
once again the prohibition includes any
practice treatment or service
wording that encompasses literally
anything that anyone in any position
might do or say to contradict the
radical left's hair-brained theories
about sex and gender
now there is ambiguity here um tyrants
love legal ambiguity because it gives
them free reign to do essentially
whatever they want you know but there's
there's no subtlety
so notice how the bill specifically
forbids the repression of
non-cisgender and non-heterosexual
identities but does not forbid
repression the other way
so it is expressly not a crime
to impose transgenderism on a child or
homosexuality on a child
it's only a crime in the reverse
and the law is written that way that's
the way the law is written
you cannot as it says
change a person's gender identity to
cisgender
but there's nothing forbidding you from
changing it to trans
it would have been easier clearer and
less wordy to prohibit all attempts
to change or repress a person's
sexuality or gender but the bill very
conspicuously does not do that
i mean why doesn't it just say uh it's a
it's a crime to change a person's gender
identity
period
no they they specified which direction
you're not allowed to change it in
that's because the demented leftist
despots and child predators who are
behind these anti-conversion therapy
laws
um they don't actually have a problem
with sexual coercion or manipulation
they have a problem with heterosexuality
and biological science
and that's what this is really about
and they also of course have a problem
with religion
and this is an effort to criminalize
religion i mean this this is it would
not be an exaggeration to say that this
is a criminalization
of
every of all the abrahamic religions
because um
one of the most crucial aspects of their
moral teachings are are
verboten now
legally so
in fact if the term conversion therapy
means anything at all
the only sort of conversion therapy that
happens in the western world is the sort
that converts people away from
heterosexuality and biological sex not
into it
i mean only an idiot or a partisan
could look at surveys showing that 40 of
generation z identifies lgbt and
conclude that this is some sort of
natural evolution 40 percent
we're talking 300 400 500 increase
in a couple of years
now we can be sure that if this was uh
if there was a pronounced drop in lgbt
identities if the lgbt communities
community if the ranks of the lgbt
community were to shrink
over the course of a few years
rather than have this astronomic rise
the left would conclude without
hesitation that there must be a
conspiracy
of repression and eradication at work
here
and that is exactly what's happening but
going the other way
there has been a many-fold increase in
non-straight non-biological identities a
jump unlike anything the world has ever
seen period and there's nothing
accidental about it
the lgbt lobby is as i've been saying
for years running the most successful
recruitment drive in american history
and it's pretty easy for it to be
successful because they have the media
the school system corporate america and
the government on their side you know
it's easy to win converts when you have
all of the most powerful institutions in
the world working with you and
especially when your target audience are
children who don't know any better
good example this a video went viral
over the weekend showing one conversion
therapy victim uh kind of go off script
unexpectedly
the child's mother put him in front of a
camera for a tick-tock uh video for a
tick-tock live you know answering
questions and the idea was he was
supposed to deliver lgbt talking points
the ones he'd been assigned because
that's all that this child is to this
mother he's just a vessel
um
for for lgbt propaganda but you know
kids say the darndest thing sometimes so
here's how that went
white people that aren't like serial
killers like ted but does your mom say
you have to be lgbt i'm not no i think
she's what i want to be but some
fun
go ahead let's fight keep talking stay
with yourself
my mom doesn't matter if i'm up if i am
gay or a lesbian or any of that she
doesn't care all she cares about is that
i'm a part of it
and if i'm not a part of it she'll try
to convince me to i'm get join it
because i
what are you saying right now
facts that i would convince you to join
what the eligibility plus
now if the child in that video had said
that uh his mother was trying to
convince him to be straight
you know the police would have barreled
through her door
and carted her away in handcuffs by now
instead he reveals that he's being
psychologically conditioned to be some
version of gay
and his abuser will pay no price for it
there'll be no penalty no punishment
this is the approved form of conversion
therapy in america
and in
the western world
millions of children fall victim to it
it's the only kind of conversion therapy
that's allowed
and the only kind that exists
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well um as you can see i'm not in the
studio again due to global warming we
had yet another snowstorm here in
tennessee multiple snowstorms in
tennessee in a span of a month and um
that that uh that does prove global
warming you know that's that's proof of
global warming um actually no i'm sorry
it proves climate change
right it proves that climate change
exists because it proves that climates
change the climate changes
which if you had any doubt about whether
the climate changes
then uh then exhibit a is right outside
my window
the great thing about the climate change
idea is that literally anything that
happens is evidence for it
so it's the most unfalsifiable theory of
all time
cold
climate change is it hot outside climate
change rain climate change wind climate
change tornadoes climate change
hurricane climate change
is it mild and calm well climate change
volcanic eruption climate change stubbed
your toe climate change racism climate
change
um climate change i think at this point
could be defined as
you know because i'm you know i'm a fan
of definitions
and i think that you you need to know
what they are in order to have any kind
of coherent conversation about anything
so what's the definition of climate
change well climate change could be
defined as
that which occurs
that's climate change all things that
occur are climate change and it's
brilliant
because if you're going to have a
doomsday call
which is what environmentalism is
the lesson that other doomsday cults
have learned is that you have to be very
vague about your predictions and your
claims because environmentalists for
decades
made the same mistakes that other cults
made around the same time frame
where they would make these specific
predictions about the stuff that would
happen in the future and then the future
came and none of that stuff was
happening so you know as we know we're
all supposed to be frozen to death by
now boiled alive drowned melted by acid
rain
all the trees are supposed to be gone
there's supposed to be no ozone layer
left anymore but none of that happened
um it was like it's like that guy who
who's like a guy several years ago
harold camping right he was the doomsday
prophet and he said he said the rapture
was going to happen and
somehow he convinced a you know a large
number of people and he gave a specific
date he said on this day it's going to
happen
and people gave away their stuff and
their homes and everything and they were
waiting for it and then uh the rapture
came and it was it was it was just
another day it was like another tuesday
it was not what anyone expected the
rapture to be so then camping said
i think what he should have said
actually is um well you know what the
rapture came
but uh we're all a bunch of scumbags and
so no one was chosen it turns out a
little bit a little bit anti-clinic but
instead he said oh it was a spiritual
rapture you see it happened invisibly
you would need to have a special
um special glasses you know that you can
buy
you could buy for uh
for 10 payments of 99.99
and but that's the only way you can see
the spiritual rapture um that that's it
and maybe that maybe the maybe the uh
climate change proponents should do
something similar they should say well
you know we ne we never got acid rain
but there's a spiritual acid rain
the acid rain
in our hearts
they could do that but instead they've
gone another direction and they've just
they've decided that um well
we we predict
that
in the future
uh climate events will occur
and then the future comes and events are
happening in the climate and they're
saying see we told you
brilliant strategy
i mean it's a brilliant strategy if
you're trying to fool a bunch of morons
which unfortunately there are a lot of
them out there and uh so that's how it
worked out okay
let's see here this is from the ap it
says a man held hostages for more than
10 hours saturday at a texas synagogue
where he could be heard ranting in a
live stream and demanding the release of
a pakistani neuroscientist who was
convicted of trying to kill u.s army
officers in afghanistan one of the four
hostages held at congregation beth
israel in colleyville was released
during the standoff three others were
rescued when authorities entered the
building around 9pm uh the hosta taker
was killed and fbi special agent in
charge matt desarno said a team would
investigate the shooting incident
law enforcement officials who were not
authorized to discuss the ongoing
investigation spoke to the ap on the
condition of anonymity uh said that the
hosta taker demanded the release of
afiyah siddiqui a pakistani
neuroscientist suspected of having ties
to al-qaeda now
the name of the terrorists in this case
is malik faisal akram
and usually we don't like to show you
you know these terrorists and everything
and what they look like and we don't
want to put their their names and faces
all over the place but i do want to show
you in this case what he looks like
because it's important context here's
what he looks like
and you have to see that
because funny enough all of the
corporate media outlets
have been describing him for for days
now as um simply a british man that's
what they're
that's how they that's the description
they decided to go with a british man
that's all we need to know about is he's
from britain
in fact early on uh i forget which
outlet it was but one of them actually
described him as a man with a british
accent
and that's how they decided to describe
now
if he had um if he had a middle eastern
accent an accent to reflect his his uh
ethnic background
do you think anyone any headline would
describe him that way man with middle
eastern
accent takes hostages not gonna happen
now we were also told even though
he actually said what his motives were
so we know that this is is an islamic
radical
um he's taking hostages on behalf of of
of another terrorists
and this is one of the there are times
when motives are unclear
right the las vegas shooting
um
hundreds of people shot
we still haven't been told his motive
because as far as we've as we know he
never said anything to anybody about it
so the motive is very unclear now many
of us have been asking for years now hey
what was that all about remember that
guy that shot all those people in las
vegas why did that happen
but the fbi and uh law enforcement
officials they claim that oh you know
who knows may it just happened
so there are there are
times when the motive is unclear
there are times when it seems like the
powers that be don't don't want us to
know the motive but in this is a case
where he actually said
what his motive was
which is pretty common for hostage
takers there's what whatever they have
they have a reason why they're doing it
they're trying to accomplish something
that's why they're taking hostages
and um usually they'll tell you what
they want and he did
and and yet in the hours after that um
fbi an fbi spokesman got in front of
cameras and said uh well you know we we
still don't know what what this was
about but it but he was not targeting
the jewish community as what we were
told listen
uh we we do believe from our engagement
with this subject that he was singularly
focused on one issue
and it was not specifically related to
the jewish community uh but we're
continuing to work to find motive and we
will continue on that path
so the fbi is confused and joe biden the
next day was asked about this and uh he
was also just confounded i mean he had
no idea why this happened listen to
biden
well
no i don't we don't have i don't think
there is
sufficient information to know about
uh
why he
targeted that synagogue why he insisted
on the release of someone who's been in
prison for over uh 10 years why he was
engaged why he
was using anti-semitic and anti-israeli
comments so i i we just don't have
enough facts
so let's see um
so we got a muslim guy
sister's a convicted terrorist takes
hostage at a synagogue takes hostages at
a synagogue in texas on a saturday
um
the sabbath
uh ed but uh no it wasn't targeting jews
had nothing to that's just coincidence
could have been anywhere right he could
have chosen any location just happens to
choose a synagogue in texas because you
know those are a dime a dozen in texas
so if you're just walking down the
street randomly looking for a place to
take hostages and
you you might
chances are you're going to stumble
across a synagogue
that's what we're supposed to believe of
course is totally absurd and
a day after this
the fbi put another statement out and
now they're saying this is a
terrorism-related matter in which the
jewish community was targeted and is
being investigated by the joint
terrorism task force
so the fbi tried to say uh this was not
anti-jewish this was not you know let's
not let's not
jump to any conclusions
very quickly they changed their they
completely reversed course without any
explanation and the reason is they're
just being roundly mocked and ridiculed
and criticized for it so that's why they
decided to change that's what we get
from the fbi
um
meanwhile of course
whenever something like this happens
and you have a member of an approved
victim group
who does something terrible
um
we're told immediately that the number
one concern the number one priority is
to make sure that other members of that
group are not um blamed for it
or not made to feel uncomfortable
that's the number one priority after all
this happens before we if people are
killed before we even put the bodies in
the ground number one priority is to
protect the feelings of the other
members of that approved victim group so
the daily beast columnist wajahat ali
hours later here's what he tweeted about
is what he was thinking immediately
after he said you're about to hear some
ugly and vicious islamophobia and
anti-muslim bigotry this weekend from
elected officials commentators and even
mainstream media hope i'm wrong people
will use it to divide jewish and muslim
communities for their political agenda
don't fall for it
um
many of them yeah because
right because it's the fault of
conservative commentators that there's
division in the muslim and jewish
community
right
i mean historically it's really it's
really all the fault of
conservative bloggers and radio hosts
it wasn't it wasn't it wasn't for us
there'd be nothing but peace and harmony
among the jewish and and uh muslim
population globally
he continues many of them will claim to
care about jewish lives as they openly
support and parrot vile anti-semitic
conspiracies they don't care about our
lives or our communities muslim is easy
synonym for terrorists and those who
downplay january 6th will now talk a lot
about national security
so take a drink if you're playing the
january 6 drinking game
maybe that'll be your first drink of the
day probably not you're probably already
stupefied drunk but uh of course we had
to get the mention of january 6th in
there
so
what we know at the left is that the
only thing that matters is um the victim
narrative of course
and they have their victim hierarchy and
this kind of
equation complicated equation well
oftentimes it's pretty simple
you know
um the victim narrative and the in the
equation is simple but there are times
when it becomes a little more
complicated for them and that's where
they start kind of stepping on their own
feet and tripping and stumbling a lot
and um that's what that's what we have
here
and i think in general for the left
for the left's victim narrative
they have a lot of trouble
with the jewish community
they're not they're
they're not quite sure what to do there
because obviously with the jews we're
talking about
a minority
um and a historically oppressed minority
clearly
but
if we're going based on skin
pigmentation especially in the united
states
you know they're white they look they
look just like any other white person
walking down the street and so that
means that they
they can't really be included in the
victim narrative
you know they they don't fall into the
victim equation
and then when you look at
conflicts overseas in the middle east
well that's where it becomes more simple
for them whoever has darker skin is the
is the victim
and um
and the victim is right you know the
victim group is always right in any
conflict
um
that's why they just can't they they
they cannot admit
um they can't go outside of the victim
narrative
and when anything happens this is always
the first concern so if there's a muslim
terrorist attack
first concern
is making sure that
nobody says any mean things to muslims
because of it
when china unleashes a deadly virus on
the world and kills 5 million people
what's the first concern there it's not
the whole china accountable that's for
sure
it's just to make sure there's no
anti-asian sentiment that's the biggest
problem
totally twisted and demented all right
let's go to the daily wire this is from
uh well it's from the daily ware as i
said new virginia republican governor
glenn younkin signed 11 executive orders
and directives on his first day in
office after being sworn in over the
weekend
uh he says quote no matter who you voted
for i pledge to be your advocate your
voice your governor
we stand here on january 15 2022 filled
with hope and optimism for the years
ahead the supernova optimism springs
from a shared vision for the future and
also from knowing what we have been
through
uh and then that's not the most
important part of course you know we got
to get the the political speech and all
that about a shared vision but but in
reality that
we don't have any shared vision in this
country for where we're going or where
we've been or what kind of country we
want to be there's no shared vision at
all but you know obviously politicians
speak this way i'm more concerned about
what he's actually doing so here's what
he actually did
the governor's office released the
following list of executive executive
actions that he signed on the very first
day
um so let's go through them executive
number one delivers on his day one
promise to restore excellence in
education by ending the use of divisive
concepts including critical race theory
and public education we got a critical
race theory ban on the first day
executive order number two that's his
and that's his first executive order on
the first day executive order number two
delivers on his day one promise to
empower virginia parents in their
in their children's education upbringing
by allowing parents to make decisions on
whether their child wears a mask in
school
so next thing he's doing is abolishing
the mask mandates in school executive
order number three delivers on his day
one promise to restore integrity and
confidence in the parole board of the
commonwealth of virginia addressing law
and order executive number four delivers
on his day one promise to investigate
wrongdoing in loudoun county
the cover-up of the horrific rape of
multiple girls around loudoun county
exactly executive order number five
delivers on his day one promise to make
government work for virginians by
creating the commonwealth chief
transformation officer not exactly sure
what that means executive order number
six delivers on his day when promised to
declare virginia open for business
uh then number seven delivers uh promise
to combat and prevent human trafficking
number eight
uh
establishes a commission to combat
anti-semitism
number nine delivers on his day one
promise to withdraw from the regional
greenhouse gas initiative
um
uh let's see what else we have
promised to jump start our economy by
cutting job killing regulations by 25
percent and then day one promise this is
his number his last one was uh to
restore individual freedoms and personal
privacy by rescinding the vaccine
mandate for all state employees okay
and apparently this is i guess this is
included in one of the executive orders
but i saw some leftists on twitter
complaining
that um that he also got rid of on this
on the state's official website there's
no page now for uh
diversity the diversity and inclusion
office
so he got rid of the page and got rid of
the office hopefully both and they're
very upset about that and that's great
too
um
this is it's only one day but
this is a shall we say a very good start
and this is exactly what republicans
should be doing
you don't try to ease your way into it
you're not going to be gradual about it
now you come in right away on offense
using all the power you have at your
disposal
to
um
put the this agenda into action
an agenda which is focused on
basic sanity uh
parental rights
you know that sort of thing you use all
the power that you have
to do it right away without waiting
going on offense
um
hopefully a lesson to other republicans
and i'll tell you this
and i i would i would not have said this
even prior to his first day
i mean i was happy that he was elected
obviously
but uh what i'll say now is if he
continues
and can string together a bunch of days
like this one
then uh i think he's a
potentially formidable candidate 2024.
we'll see
ralph northam he's the guy on the way
out in virginia and uh he did an
interview over the weekend reflecting on
his time in office and especially on the
most interesting event from that time
listen to this
well that was a very very difficult time
for virginia
there was a lot of hurt because of that
and for that i i regret uh putting
virginia through that i i also jonathan
saw it as an opportunity for
me to listen to people i i committed
myself and
our cabinet secretaries to to really
deal with the inequities that exist and
and to listen to learn and as i've said
that the more i know the more i can do
and we've really been able to turn a lot
of what we learned uh into action now in
a lot of different areas and so you know
at the end of the day it was a hurtful
time i am glad that virginians stuck
with me i can tell you that i'm a better
person
i certainly understand
racial issues much better than i did
prior to that episode and i and i really
think virginia more importantly is is a
better commonwealth a commonwealth that
is more open more inclusive
oh you see it was uh it was really it
was a good thing for everybody the
virginia virginia is a better
commonwealth now
because their governor wore blackface
and he learned an important lesson about
not wearing blackface and uh this has
been this has really been he said it's
not just about me this alerting it's
been a learning curve for everybody you
know
nobody knew that you weren't supposed to
wear blackface we all learned it
together
no ralph uh really it was just you
could not be happier i mean
it's it's
it's hard to deserve hard to deserve
this this fate more than more than he
does to leave finally in disgrace um
and this is somebody with with no
political future at all and that's
a very good thing all right this is from
ky3 in missouri it says an illinois
school district released a statement
defending a controversial after school
club after flyer sponsored by the
satanic temple surfaced at an elementary
school within the district
the after-school satan club is set to
have its first meeting thursday the
flyer found within the moline cole
valley school district is advertised for
first through fifth graders regardless
of religious background and ask for
permission from parents or guardians or
students to attend uh the flyer says the
the club is set to meet from 2 45 to 3
45 once a month
dates are provided up until may
so this is a
elementary school with an after-school
satan club
and maybe like you when i first saw this
story i really thought it was a joke
um this is one of those moments where i
my first initial reaction was that's oh
that's a babylon bee thing
a little bit too on the nose not one of
their funnier headlines uh then you read
it and you know it's it's real this is a
very real thing
and the statement the district has put
up this statement defending it here's
what they say the moline cole valley
school district understands that there
is a concern and confusion over an
upcoming after-school club at jane adams
elementary
the district would like to provide
information on the situation
the mullein cole valley school district
and board of education have policies and
administrative procedures in place which
allow for community use of its public
publicly funded facilities outside the
school day the district does not
discriminate against any groups who wish
to rent our facilities including
religious affiliated groups religiously
affiliated groups are among those
allowed to rent our facilities for free
the district has in the past approved
these types of groups one example being
the good news club which is an after
school child evangel evangelism
fellowship group flyers and promotional
materials for these types of groups are
approved for lobby postings or display
only and not for mass distribution
um
and then he talks it says this is about
equal asp equal access and all of that
so they're drawing a direct comparison
between a christian evangelism group you
know an after-school bible study type of
thing
and a satan club
i think what we
there are a few things we lessons we
learned from this
a few takeaways we should say one is
should be the most obvious get your kids
the hell out of the public school system
um
every day there's another story which
should emphasize that fact to you
but the other is this um
even on the right
you know
you often hear this clamoring for
uh we need
um open dialogue in the school system
freedom of thought you know that's what
this is all about
and so when quote unquote conservative
ideas are excluded
or punished
or ostracized or marginalized
then uh then even people on the right
will say we'll say that the real problem
is that this is an attack on open
dialogue and uh free speech and freedom
of expression and freedom of thought
that's not really it
right the the focus of education the
point of education
um
the foundation of it
is truth that's what matters
that's what you need in the school
system
that's what the education should be
centered around
is teaching children truth
bringing them up in the truth fortifying
them in the truth
that's why the public school education
and the universe university system are
both basically useless because they
don't not only do they not care about
the truth but they're openly hostile to
it
but that's the point
and when for example it's uh verboden in
the school system to talk about
biological science as it pertains to sex
the problem there is not that
conservatives are being picked on or
that again this is an attack on open
dialogue or whatever no it's it's that
the truth
this is not a conservative idea this
isn't a political idea the truth
is being
banished from the school system
that's what matters
because when you focus only yeah we just
want open everything is free and open
and open-mindedness
well then the satan club can come along
and say hey what about us
you said we're open right so why can't
we have our satan club in the middle of
the elementary school
why can't we try
to indoctrinate children into literal
satanism
on school grounds
because you guys are talking about open
dialogue and this is part of the open
dialogue
no satanism is an assault on truth
which is why it does not belong in the
school system
anything that is true does
to me it's as simple as that
let's get now to the comment section
[Music]
so this is exciting a little bit of a of
a change here uh we're not really
changed we're just we're adding
something to the comment section we um
now have a feature where if you want to
be featured in the in the comment
section we will now take video comments
so you can have your face
out there if you if for some reason you
want it out there and associated with
this show then you could submit video
comments you can go now to dailywire.com
appropriately sweet baby comments so
that's uh dailywire.com sweet baby
comments and you go to the page and
you'll see of course the big disturbing
picture of me and a diaper and then uh
you just gotta
what you gotta do first is upload this
to youtube and then you submit the
youtube link and your email address then
there's the terms and conditions where
you're signing your soul over to us
don't worry about that then you submit
it and um i'll look at it and uh if it's
interesting
then we'll air and i'll respond to it
and even if it's not interesting and i
just need content i'll still air it and
respond and respond to it so
dailywire.com sweet baby comments okay
marianne says i appreciate matt's show
he's a good strong ethical man i thought
we had lost this quality of manhood good
strong ethical women like um like men
like matt who exude ethics morals and
common sense well i totally agree with
your assessment of me and but the one
thing you forgot to mention of course is
my humility and i appreciate that aaron
levitt says you're absolutely right matt
college was oversold to me with the same
heavenly promises it was to you yeah
it's sold to everybody that way and then
on the flip side of it you're also
promised or rather threatened warned
that if you don't go to college that
your life is going to be a failure
and at least in my experience going to
public school for 12 years 13 years if
you count kindergarten
um
they they're they're not subtle i mean
they're quite aggressive in in sending
that message
mean bean comedy says
i like hearing how sweet matt's wife is
and how she helps to
balance him out
like i said i it's it's it's a cliche i
think at least in my case it's really
it's really the case that uh opposites
attract and because we we could not be
more
diametrically
uh opposed
well i guess that's clear there's
actually some
important clarification there
um
or or qualification anyway which is that
i think
that
personality wise that's where that's the
case
i think probably to tr i can't imagine
being married to someone who has the
same personality as me the last thing i
would want to to do is be around i have
to
live in my own body i want to be around
another version of myself that would be
horrible
so that's where the opposites come in
but it's important to be
similar if not the same when it comes to
your fundamental foundational values and
principles that's where it matters
um
if you're if you're an opposite if
you're opposites as far as that goes
that's where you could really be in
trouble in your relationship
um
dh says matt you can do an at-home sleep
study which is very accurate at
diagnosing sleep apnea and other
sleep-related issues and it's infinitely
more comfortable and convenient than the
lab test that you described i would
highly recommend it so how does that
work does my wife have to stay awake at
night and just watch me sleep and take
notes
if that's the case maybe i'll do it
because forcing her to do that would be
very funny
um
let's see
me says wow man i'm so disappointed but
i guess i guess it's to be expected i am
an rn fired for not getting vaccinated i
signed your petition and was was all in
with this fight you could at least
mention that the mandate is still in
place for health care workers thanks to
kavanaugh and roberts but i guess you
got your victory sort of hell with the
rest of us
well you know i got to say i'm i'll
never understand an attitude like this
uh i'm sorry you were fired from your
job
that's horrible and wrong and tyrannical
and in infringement on your rights
but you're mad that i talked about one
thing and not another thing
you know we tend to focus on one thing
at a time so this is it's a it's a real
common criticism of people you know if
you have a platform and you do a show
you
every day you'll get this why did you
talk about this and not that over there
this this subject over here is way more
important than that subject it might be
but i can't talk about every subject on
every show you see how that works
the fact that we got this win with
private employers is very very important
and it's worth focusing on
and uh you know what sometimes i i i
think it's good to just focus on the
victory
and even to revel in it a little bit
when you have those moments
instead of always having to couch
everything and saying yeah but you know
what it's also a failure for this reason
all right elizabeth says matt has so
many closing lines why not add a few
more thanks for watching thanks for
listening love you have a great day
enjoy your meal god speed may the road
rise up to meet you remember the only
thing worth viewing is fear itself once
a king or queen and arya narnia always a
king or queen and narnia don't let the
bed bugs bite
i guess i do have i kind of take a peter
jackson approach to endings i can't
have any qualms with you there
and finally walter says dear matt i love
your youtube episodes except when you
attack trump-heavy people and people
that may not look like perfect tens for
any reason
you're excellent of what you do and
please stay on point
okay first of all um attacking fat
people in ugly people is way more
offensive than attacking trump
so i wouldn't put those all together
trump is a politician
so
he's always open to be attacked
and
we should always be eager to criticize
politicians of all stripes as americans
that should that should that should be
one of our fundamental values as
americans
is a is a is a permanent
skepticism towards politicians and an
eagerness to hold them accountable and
criticize them when they deserve it and
even sometimes when they don't because
it's fun
um
as far as but as far as overweight
people i don't attack
fat people overweight people
you know pointing out that obesity is
harmful and will kill you
and there's nothing to be celebrated
that's not an attack
and like so many other things on the
show i wouldn't be talking about it
i wouldn't spend time talking about
the fact that obesity is bad unless you
had
a powerful voice on the other side
saying no actually it's good
so i have to respond to that
in an ideal world in a sane world
i wouldn't spend any time saying obesity
is bad because everybody wouldn't know
it there'd be no reason to say it
but when there's a concerted effort and
a campaign to get people to embrace
obesity thereby embracing their own
physical destruction
then it's necessary to say no it's bad
as far as ugly people you know whatever
i say about ugly people is fine because
i'm a member of the community and those
are the rules you know we're allowed to
defame
each other if we're all in the community
together
very excited to announce the release of
the poster for our first original
production shut-in which is a seat
gripping thriller that'll be available
to stream in february the film follows
the story of a young mother who's
barricaded inside a closet by her
violent ex-husband as she's trapped
inside she uses nothing but her voice to
guide her children on the other side of
the walls to safety all while the threat
of her dangerous ex looms we seriously
cannot wait to share the finished
product with you so make sure you catch
the final trailer when it drops tomorrow
if you're planning on adding this
terrifying thriller to your queue and
want us to keep making content to combat
the over politicized mainstream
entertainment that you get on the major
streaming platforms then go like and
share the trailer on youtube
your support makes all the difference
and
uh it seems like it's been a while since
we've done one of these but the daily
wire was one of the first in the nation
to file suit against the byte
administration's tyrannical vaccine
mandates and our case made it to the
supreme court who ultimately sided with
us and blocked the mandates tomorrow
night we are going to have a brand new
episode of backstage it is back at last
where we discussed the outcome of the
supreme court ruling and so much more
join me ben shapiro jeremy bourne
michael knowles and andrew clavin
tomorrow night at 7 00 p.m eastern 6 p.m
central on dailywire.com and on our
youtube channel daily wire now let's get
to our daily cancellation
[Music]
we cancel tick tock influencer knot bay
who has uh several hundred thousand
followers on this site and um recently
posted a video which has since gone
viral across multiple platforms in the
video miss uh knob bay responds to a
commentator or a comment or other who
was lamenting the state of modern
womanhood and the commenter said i
honestly don't know what modern women
bring to a relationship they don't want
to work clean cook or raise children yet
complain about everything
now the comment of course does not apply
to all modern women uh doesn't apply to
my wife for example but as a general
statement it's it's quite astute
kay felt otherwise though and she
responded and her response echoed i
think echoes a very common sentiment in
our culture today which is why it's
worth listening to and engaging with
let's uh listen
we're not bringing nothing to
relationships for centuries decades
we've seen our grandmothers our mothers
our great aunts give
everything and get nothing
so for the first time in history we're
saying no you don't get a free incubator
you don't get a free maid you don't get
a free chef
we're saying no and y'all losing your
mind
no ma'am and then y'all calling me a
feminist
if you know me you know like i still
want susan b anthony here so that's not
even the thing y'all just need a label
to put on somebody who's telling y'all
no
we said step y'all y'all made podcasts
that don't seem weird
all right a few points here first of all
what is this we stuff
right even if i agreed that
you know if i even if i agreed with the
proposition
that women in history were universally
oppressed and as you say they gave
everything and got nothing
um which i don't agree with that but if
i did what the hell does that have to do
with you
you know if it was the k if that was the
case in the past it wasn't but if it was
it certainly isn't true today
so you have like 300 000 followers on on
tick tock despite the fact that you've
never said anything interesting in your
life
so you give nothing and get everything
those are your circumstances and the
circumstances of so many others in
modern culture
when it comes to the conversation about
alleged historical oppression
sometimes those of us on the rational
side of the debate we get so caught up
in trying to to debunk the historical
claim or frame it correctly or lend it
context or whatever
but we forget to mention just how
absolutely ridiculous it is for a
privileged whiny brat
luxuriating in the comforts of 21st
century western culture to try to
exploit historical suffering that she
didn't experience
so she approaches this with a sort of uh
we're tired of being treated this way
and uh and we're not gonna take it
anymore
but what the hell are you tired of
nothing happened to you you were born
into a country where women have all the
same legal rights as men in fact have
more legal rights than men
so please stop acting exhausted by
traumas that you never suffered
as if you inherited them in your
bloodstream or something that's not how
suffering works
but what about the claim that um
that women of the past gave everything
and got nothing
well that would be true
if a roof over your head
and food on the table
and close on your back and everything
else you need to survive and thrive and
be comfortable if all of that amounts to
nothing
then sure
i mean if everything is nothing then
it's true that women got nothing but
then again it's also true that they gave
nothing
because uh everything is nothing and
nothing is anything
now i'm kind of confused
but if words mean something however it
would be more true to say that women in
the past
gave one thing you know they they had
something that they gave
and men gave something else
and that's how they structured their
societies
they each gave they each contributed in
different ways
right
of course we're just pretending here
that women started working outside of
the house 30 years ago or something
which isn't true
that's obviously not the case even back
in the middle ages many guilds had women
members for example
but that aside the traditional gender
roles she talks about um were not at all
one-sided as they're so often
caricatured today
they could not have been one-sided right
prior to the industrial age unless you
were nobility
or royalty or in the ruling class you
you had to actually survive on a daily
basis
and survival required effort required
work
every day
if anyone in your house gave nothing
everything would fall apart
and everybody would probably die that's
why no no one in the house gives nothing
unless unless we're talking about
infants
but even older children had to
contribute
they didn't have the luxury to
experiment with sending women out into
the forest to hunt while the men stayed
home to nurse the babies
never occurred to them to do it
they didn't have the luxury to do it
the person best fit for the job had to
do it
and that's largely why the gender roles
historically
uh worked out the way they did
because men were simply best fit to do
these kinds of things
and you you needed the person best fit
to do it
to go out and do it so that you could
survive
nobody was concerned with equity back
then because equity is the kind of thing
that people can only concern themselves
with when they have nothing else to
worry about
men and women contributed differently
but they both contributed
because there was no other option
now today survival does not necessitate
the same sort of constant and conscious
effort the welfare state has in fact
made it possible for people to survive
without any effort at all in some cases
aside from whatever minimal exertions
are necessary to walk from the couch to
the refrigerator and then back to the
couch again
to grab another armful of food that you
know you didn't pay for and even those
of us who who work are still not
fighting to survive the way that people
in the past did
it's only in the midst of this obscene
affluence that almost all of us are
experiencing that we can start tinkering
with gender roles right
instead of of men doing one thing and
women doing another now we say that men
and women should all do the same things
and sex should not factor into how the
work is delegated at all
but it's hard to argue that this
arrangement has been a smashing success
as marriages are falling apart at a
rapid rate the family unit itself is
disintegrating
there's also hostility and resentment
between the sexes as evidenced by this
woman's response and the comment she's
responding to
somehow this uh this idea of you know
we'll both do the same thing and
contribute in exactly the same way
and neither of us will have any
pronounced roles at all this strategy
has not brought about the results that
we were promised
shocking
and there are many reasons for that but
let me focus on just one this is not the
whole case that i could make but it's
just just one element here
the fuel that keeps human relationships
in general and marriages in particular
running smoothly is is gratitude
okay that's the fuel
it would not be an exaggeration to say
that probably nearly every failed
marriage or most of them
or failed romantic relationships of any
kind
fail because of a terminal lack of
gratitude by one or both partners
usually both
now if you listen to two divorce
divorcees talk about each other this is
one of the first things that will jump
out at you is that is that they are not
grateful for the others contributions to
the marriage
they don't recognize the contributions
all
and
they both feel that the other was not
grateful for their contributions
this is like almost every divorced
couple
or former couple you come across
even in cases where the primary cause of
the divorce seems to be something like
infidelity
even then a lack of gratitude lies at
the root of it because only a person who
lacks gratitude for their spouse would
cheat on them in the first place
so what does this have to do with the
gender role question well
it's easier to be grateful for your
spouse's contributions if you know what
those contributions are
okay if you know what their role is
then it's easier to be grateful for it
instead of these days both partners
looking at each other like what exactly
do you do here
why do i need you
and crucially
if you recognize that they are bringing
something unique and essential to the
table
that they're providing something to your
household that you could not provide
yourself
if you have the attitude that there is
no important difference between you and
your spouse
and um that you can do everything that
they can do and probably do it better
then naturally you're not going to be
grateful for them
they are a redundancy at best
unnecessary baggage at worst
and pretty soon you start seeing it the
way uh our friend kay sees it you you
you you give everything they give
nothing
and whatever little bit maybe they do
give you could do you could give the
same and do a better job of it than they
do that's why people like kay will never
have a successful relationship or
marriage or even friendship for that
matter
because a woman like her declares that
she is perfect
you know that she don't need no man that
men ought to be grateful for her no
matter uh how little she brings to the
table and that she won't be grateful for
men no matter how much they bring to the
table
and then women like this sit back in
astonishment
and wonder why they're alone
well
there's no mystery there
there's also no mystery to the fact that
today
she is canceled
and we'll leave it there thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pavel
voldowsky the show is edited by robbie
dantzler our audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is done by
cherokee heart and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters the matte
wall show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2022
today on the ben shapiro show after an
islamic extremist takes hostages at a
synagogue the fbi announces its
puzzlement over motive that's today on
the bench bureau shall give it a listen